we were confused when we were asked to
introduce our next presenters Pedro and
Quinton because those are our pet names
for each other
ladies and gentlemen Academy Award
winners Pedro almodóvar and Quentin
Tarantino
it's really great to meet you Pedro I've
been a fan of your films for such a long
time yeah I loved used to acquaintance
even though I really don't understand a
word of them well that how appropriate
is for us to introduce best foreign
language film here are the nominees a
Jame
from misery directed by Skandera Coptic
and you're on Shani the milk of sorrow
latecha a sustad from Peru
directed by Claudia your son a profit
nonprofit from France directed by
Jacques Odia the secret in their eyes el
secreto de sus ojos from Argentina
directed by Juan Jose Campanella the
white ribbon the slice a bomb from
Germany directed by Miguel Hanna okay
the winner is el secreto de sus ojos the
cigarette in their eyes
Argentina 12 si Campanella
this is the second Academy Award and six
nomination for Argentina
gracias
it is on behalf of a crew and cast that
comprised mostly of people that I love
and that are very close to my heart that
I want to thank the Academy for not
considering Navia foreign language first
of all and for letting us spend three
great days in the company of incredible
filmmakers on on a personal note I would
love to thank my producers Gerardo Reed
Oh Marilla Vesuvius even a ceremony
except Uche Rocky and tell FA Tom
Barnard sorry it in English is more
difficult it's a little slower
no no Oh countdown okay Tom Barnard and
Michael Barker from Sony classics and
Cecelia you you found a guy stuck in
development hell and made something
watchable out of him thank you so much I
love you I owe you
what will happily swap out how thank you
thank you thank you thank you
vamos Argentina you never have to send
another teen
you